Welcome to you, our listener.
We are really glad you were here with us today because we are looking at a remarkable and honestly very demanding book called Establishing the Imamite.
Yeah, it's definitely not a light read.
No, not at all.
It is a text written by *** Saburi.
And from this point forward, just to keep things smooth, we will simply refer to him as the author.
Makes sense?
So our entire exploration today is going to orient around a single profound claim.
Its summit is 1 figure whose dealings mirror God's own.
And to frame our exploration for you listening, we should probably establish that we are stepping into the classical Ismaili reading of this text today.
Yes, exactly.
We are entering a highly specific framework of theological inquiry.
This is a tradition that asks us to look far beyond the conventional boundaries of how we understand
human leadership or I mean how we understand human excellence generally.
Yeah, and ultimately how we understand the divine order of the universe itself.
Exactly.
To anchor everything we are going to discuss, we really must begin with the core thesis of this work.
It is a single sentence, but it holds the entire architecture of the author's argument.
Listen closely to this proposition.
The Emam treats people
as God treats them, giving to the faithful and the faithless alike, seeking nothing in return, and that, not the power of a king, is the mark of God's vice Hugent.
That sentence is really the absolute center of gravity for our discussion.
It really is.
But to understand how the author arrives at such a staggering conclusion and to understand why he views ordinary kingly power as totally insufficient,
We have to start where he starts.
We cannot just jump straight into the theology of leadership.
No, that would skip too many steps.
Right, we have to begin with the fundamental structure of reality itself.
The author observes what he considers to be a universal rule written into the very fabric of everything that exists in the natural world.
He begins by outlining this foundational argument about how nature operates, like from the ground up.
He observes a rule that he believes is undeniable, which is that nature does not spread its excellence evenly.
It's not democratic at all.
Not at all.
In every species, in every genus, in every root and branch of the natural order, excellence is gathered to a single point.
Nature takes all of its dispersed virtues, all of its potential, and it
It concentrates them into a summit.
And he provides very specific examples to build this logic, asking his readers to simply look at the world around them.
Yeah, to observe the hierarchy inherent in creation.
Consider the elements, for example.
Among all the metals found in the earth, one stands supreme, and that is gold.
Which, in the classical understanding, is the metal that totally resists corruption.
Exactly.
It does not rust.
It does not tarnish in the way lesser metals do.
It holds its purity over time.
The ancient mind viewed gold not just as, you know, valuable for trade or currency, but as the metaphysical peak of what a metal could possibly be.
And the author continues this observation systematically across different domains of the natural world.
He moves from metals to stones, pointing to the ruby that will not burn.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah, and then he moves to the Plank Kingdom.
Among the grains that nourish us, the peak of that category is wheat.
Among the trees, it is the date palm.
So he's cataloging the peaks of every natural category.
Exactly.
And then he asks us to look up into the heavens.
Among all the celestial bodies, the summit is the outermost sphere and the sun.
The sun stands as the undeniable peak of the heavenly bodies, illuminating and governing the entire system it belongs to.
The underlying philosophy here is just vital to grasp if we are going to follow his argument.
The author is suggesting that hierarchy is not some artificial construct imposed upon the world by human beings.
It is the intrinsic language of creation itself.
It's built into this system.
Yes.
Whenever a category of things exists, it must inevitably point upward to a singular expression of its highest potential.
The existence of the lesser implies the necessity of the greatest.
If there are metals, the logic dictates there must be gold.
Exactly.
If there are stars, there must be the sun.
Nature abhorring a vacuum also means nature demands A pinnacle.
And he extends this logic of the natural world directly to humanity itself.
Just as the natural world gathers its excellence to a point, the wisdom of the whole world, of all the animals, the plants, the minerals, comes to its full expression only in the emergence of the human being.
Humanity represents the summit of nature.
Yes, humanity is the summit.
The well-being of all creation is completed through humanity, and the benefit of every created thing flows back to mankind.
But the ascent does not stop there, does it?
No, it doesn't.
The author is building a ladder.
He is arguing that if nature culminates in humanity, then humanity itself must culminate in something.
The excellence of the human race cannot be evenly distributed any more than the excellence of metals is evenly distributed.
It must also be gathered to a point.
Following this exact logic, the line of spiritual guides the office of the I
must also rise to a single point.
So the rule of summits applies to the spiritual realm too.
Completely.
There can be no exemption from the rule of summits for the highest realm of all.
Just as humanity is the peak of nature, the guides are the peak of humanity.
And just as the guides are the peak of humanity, the whole line of those guides must itself rise to 1 supreme peak.
So it narrows and narrows.
Yes.
And the author names this pinnacle figure plainly.
He is the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
He is also referred to as the father of imams or the first imam.
Okay, I see.
He is introduced as the summit of all summits, the furthest limit beyond which there's no further limit.
The language the author uses is incredibly deliberate there, the summit of summits.
He is closing the door on any higher term.
He really is shutting it tight.
Because a mountain peak is a summit, but it is just one summit among many mountains.
The author is positing that the father of imams is the apex where the entire hierarchy of peaks finally comes to rest.
There is no higher point to reach in the whole architecture of human spiritual excellence.
And to make this vivid, the author provides a necessary image, and we must explore it fully because it operates as the engine for the rest of his historical argument.
The anatomy metaphor.
Yes, he asks us to envision the human body.
The father of imams, he explains, is the head, and all the past guides and prophets are the body.
Naturally, the head governs the body.
Right, that is a common enough metaphor.
It is, but he goes deeper into the anatomy of spiritual life.
He says the father of imams is the spirit, and no body is complete or alive without its spirit.
And then he arrives at the ultimate bodily image.
He says the father of imams is the heart.
The beating heart.
Yes.
The central vital organ.
Because in classical physiology, the heart was understood as the singular source of heat, life, and the vital spirit that animates the entire physical form.
Exactly.
All the past prophets, figures like Moses, Jesus, Abraham, and all the guides who came before are like the limbs.
They are the hands, the hair, the nails.
Right, so the previous prophets are just limbs in this analogy.
Yes.
And we know that every limb, down to the smallest extremity, receives its life, its nourishment, and its vitality solely through the beating of that one central organ.
Without the heart pumping life outward, the limbs are lifeless.
They possess no independent power.
This image totally reorients our entire understanding of time and spiritual history.
It really does bend time, doesn't it?
Yeah, because we usually think of time as purely chronological.
The past is finished and the present is alive.
But by using imamate of the heart and the limbs, the author is arguing that the entire body of guidance stretching all the way back through history is a single living organism.
Yes, a single unified body.
And it only lives because this one figure stands at its center,
spiritual vitality into every prophet and guide that preceded him.
That is the exact mechanism of his claim.
The father of his moms is the perfector.
The specific term the author uses is the mutimm, the one who completes and brings to fullness.
He gathers it all together.
He gathers within himself all the merits of everyone who came before every prophet, every guide, every sage, all their knowledge, their steadfastness, their benefit, convergence him.
and he surpasses them.
So everything culminates in him.
Yes, and the author draws a direct parallel to make this clear.
Just as the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, drew his merit by gathering into himself the merits of all who lived in the cycles before him,
The father of imams completes their order.
He gathers the inheritance of the past and perfects it.
I have a serious problem with this timeline, though.
Oh, lay it out.
If we are following the logic of a ladder of excellence, where everything points to a final ultimate peak,
Why is this summit located in the historical past?
I see what you're getting at.
Yeah.
If this figure is the ultimate perfector of everything, the summit of all summits for whose sake the worlds exist, doesn't that title naturally belong to some distant final figure at the very end of time?
It's a very fair question.
In almost every theological framework, the ultimate perfection is an eschatological event.
It happens at the end of history to seal all cycles.
Why is the author centering this absolute perfection here rather than placing it at the very end of days?
The author anticipates that exact friction.
It is a brilliant objection, and his resolution requires A radical pivot in how we understand the text.
Okay, what's the pivot?
He explains that the I'm am of the age continues that exact summit today.
The summit of summits is not a fixed point sealed away in history, trapped in the past.
It is a living station.
A living station, meaning the office itself holds the summit, not just the historical figure.
The current imam of the age stands in exactly that place for his own time.
He completes the cycle for his own age, gathering the entire inheritance into the present.
So it is continually realized.
Yes.
The author uses numerical language to explain this, describing how a cycle opened by others is brought to perfection by the one who follows, much as the human
human creature is perfected over time in the womb.
That makes a lot of sense.
The father of imams is the historical summit, the heart and spirit of the body of guidance.
And the reigning imam of the age is the one who continues and completes that summit in the present, gathering all past inheritance into himself.
They are not separate summits.
They are one continuous ascent made present in every era.
So the perfection is not deferred to the end of time and it is not locked in some museum of historical veneration.
No, it is highly active.
It is realized in the present moment through the living guide.
That completely changes the stakes of the entire treatise.
We are not just analyzing the biography of a historical figure.
We are talking about an active, ongoing reality in the world.
And that brings us to the most crucial pivot in the author's argument.
He has established the cosmological rule that the world must have a summit.
He has identified who that summit is, both historically and in the present.
Now he must prove the why.
This specific figure.
Exactly.
Why does this figure represent the ultimate peak of human excellence?
To prove this, he turns his attention to the highest ideals of human thought.
He turns to philosophy.
He does.
In the classical tradition, philosophy was not just an academic exercise.
it had a very specific, exalted definition of its own ultimate goal.
The philosophers argued that the highest pursuit of a human being is to achieve resemblance to the creator, so far as humanly possible.
That was the peak of their ambition.
To be a philosopher was to strive to mirror the divine in one's character, one's knowledge, and one's actions.
We even see this mapped out in the cosmology of an earlier philosopher of the same tradition who beautifully illustrated how the ranks of religion mirror the structure of the heavens.
They built magnificent, intricate systems around this idea of resembling the creator.
But here is where the author delivers a devastating critique of that entire intellectual tradition.
He takes that philosophical definition perfectly seriously.
He agrees entirely that the highest human pursuit is resemblance to the creator.
But then he claims that philosophy fundamentally failed to realize it in practice.
The philosophers drew the target flawlessly, but not one of them ever actually hit it.
Because to truly resemble the Creator, one cannot simply philosophize about the cosmos or write treatises on metaphysics.
One must act in the world.
To seek resemblance to the Creator means to deal with mankind the way God deals with them.
It means interacting with people, distributing fortune, and governing in the exact manner of God's own conduct.
Oh, I see where this is going.
And the author reveals his central claim here.
Only the Imam actually achieves this resemblance to the Creator.
The philosophers theorize the resemblance.
The imam alone embodies it in his daily conduct.
This is the pivot.
This is the moment the entire cosmological setup has been driving toward.
And to solidify this pivot, we must state the core thesis again.
Please do.
The imam treats people as God treats them, giving to the faithful and the faithless alike, seeking nothing in return, and that, not the power of the king, is the mark of God's vice deodrum.
Okay, I have to stop you there.
I completely disagree that this behavior is praiseworthy.
You do.
Yes, we have to steelman this argument, because when you actually look at what you are describing, treating the faithful and the faithless exactly alike, it sounds profoundly unjust.
How so?
If we look at how we measure human excellence and leadership, we expect a good king to be described.
A just ruler rewards loyalty, protects the righteous, and punishes his enemies.
A king makes his favor legible so that treacherous behavior is checked and virtue is encouraged.
That is the standard expectation, yes.
If a leader treats the faithless exactly as well as the faithful, providing for them equally without distinction, that feels like a betrayal of justice.
It sounds capricious.
Why would the highest human excellence look like moral indifference?
It is a vital objection.
The author knows how offensive this idea sounds when judged by the standards of ordinary kingship.
But he dismantles this objection by looking not at how human kings govern, but at how God governs the divine economy.
God's govern.
Yes.
The author asks us to observe the plainest, most undeniable fact about worldly fortune.
God bestows blessing on people whether they are pious or impious.
He gives to believers and unbelievers alike, and he withholds from both in turn.
That is true in experience.
The author anchors this directly in scripture.
In chapter 13, verse 26, it is stated plainly that God extends provision to whom he wills and restricts it.
He grants and denies at different times to each, completely regardless of their piety.
You cannot argue with the reality of that observation.
The righteous often suffer in grinding poverty, while the corrupt often accumulate massive, generation-spanning wealth.
The rain falls on the just and the unjust, but observing that it happens is different from explaining why a perfect guide would emulate it.
The author explains the profound why behind this divine economy.
Think about it.
If God were to govern like an ordinary human king, if he only rewarded believers with wealth, health, and prosperity, and aggressively denied those things to unbelievers, then faith itself would be destroyed.
It would become a mere business calculation.
Precisely.
People would flock to religion not out of genuine devotion or spiritual awakening, but purely for the sake of profit.
Their obedience would be a transaction about securing comfort in this world.
not a turning toward God.
Faith would be indistinguishable from a profitable career choice.
Exactly.
If piety always equaled a full stomach and a heavy purse, you would never know who actually loved God and who just loved the payout.
And conversely, if God only rewarded unbelievers with wealth and systematically withheld all worldly good from believers, then most people's faith would collapse into absolute despair.
Who could hold to a religion that guaranteed them starvation and ruin in this life?
So God must thread the needle between those two extremes.
He must.
God extends and restricts provision across all categories to protect the integrity of faith itself.
By giving and withholding from both the pious and the impious, God ensures that obedience is never bought by worldly advantage and never abandoned for the lack of it.
That makes a ton of sense.
And the author argues that the imam of the age mirrors this exact economy.
He bestows worldly benefit on the believer and the hypocrite alike and withholds from both.
He gives to the righteous and the immoral, to the ignorant and the learned.
He imitates the divine balance perfectly.
And in doing so, he prevents his followers from turning their devotion to him into a transaction.
Exactly.
If he only rewarded those who were demonstrably loyal, people would perform belief just to win his favor.
their faith would become a courtship, a theatrical performance for material gain, rather than genuine conviction.
Furthermore, the Imam hides the means of his generosity, just as God has hidden the workings of the world.
God keeps the methods of worldly gain obscure.
One person prospers in trade while another goes bankrupt.
One flourishes in farming while another loses the seed he planted.
It's unpredictable.
Yes.
And if there were a single guaranteed formula for wealth universally known, everyone would abandon their diverse, necessary paths in life to pour down that one Rd.
The ordered variety of the world would be corrupted.
The entire structure of human society relies on that unpredictability.
It really does.
If there were a guaranteed formula
wealth, everyone would abandon their posts.
No one would bake bread.
No one would build houses.
No one would teach because they would all be exploiting the single known formula for riches.
Society would collapse.
And so the Imam conceals the means of gaining benefit through him in the exact same way.
If there were a formula for his bounty, if people discovered a definite method for obtaining his favor, all other means would become futile.
Those who lack that one key.
I see.
By keeping the grounds of his generosity hidden, he keeps hope open for everyone and certainty available to no one.
It creates a highly specific psychological environment.
By drawing near and then withdrawing, by granting and withholding without a legible transactional formula, the leader prevents complacency.
The author describes it as keeping the soul perpetually suspended between fear and hope.
Fear and hope.
Yes.
If the leader is always near, always predictable, and always rewarding,
The followers grow bold and complacent.
They think themselves self-sufficient.
But if the leader holds himself at a permanent distance, refusing all access, anxiety creeps in and the followers collapse into despair.
That balance is delicate.
Very.
The imam deals with people as conditions require arousing, longing, granting, withholding, punishing, forgiving all and emulation of God's manner to maintain that perfect suspension.
This is not neglect and it is not capricious cruelty.
Yeah, it's intentional.
It is the spiritual climate required to keep a human soul perfectly awake.
This completely upends the traditional concept of patronage.
We are so used to leaders whose gifts are always tethered to an expectation.
Always springs attached.
Always.
A king gives a gift to secure loyalty, to repay a debt, to discharge an obligation, or, you know, to ensure future service.
The economy of human leadership is always a transaction.
But what you are describing is a type of giving that breaks that wheel entirely.
It breaks it into pieces.
It is an open hand moving purely out of a fullness that answers only to God.
That is the ultimate distinction.
The gifts of ordinary kings cannot honestly be called generosity.
They are investments.
That is a great way to put it.
But the imam gives without seeking recompense because he is mirroring God who owes nothing to anyone.
And this brings us to a profound categorization made by the father of imams himself regarding the nature of worship and service.
Oh, yes.
The three kinds of worship.
Do you want to break those down?
Sure.
The father of imams observed that humanity's devotion can be sorted into 3 distinct categories based on their underlying psychological motivation.
Okay.
First, there are those who worship God out of a desire for reward.
They are looking for a return on their investment.
This, he said, is the worship of Mircha.
A transactional relationship.
I give you obedience, you give me paradise or worldly comfort.
Entirely transactional.
Second, there are those who worship God out of fear of punishment, fear of ruin, fear of hellfire.
This, he said, is the worship of slaves.
It is devotion extracted under duress.
Neither of those sound like the summit of human potential.
No, they don't.
But then there is the third category.
There are those who worship God out of pure gratitude.
They seek no reward and they are not driven by terror.
They give their devotion freely.
This, he said, is the worship of the free.
The worship of the free.
Yes.
The imam is giving because it asks for nothing back, because it refuses to be a transaction, demands and cultivates this exact type of devotion.
It rejects the merchants and the slaves and calls forth the worship of the free.
And it is precisely because this figure acts with this divine impartiality, demanding the worship of the free rather than
kingly transaction that he is in grave peril of being misunderstood by society.
How so?
Because he governs outside the recognizable bounds of human kingship, people misread him.
Well, this brings up the ultimate theological tension for me.
Let's hear it.
You are describing a human being who flawlessly mirrors God's actions, who distributes provision exactly as God does, who governs the divine economy on earth.
How is this different from just divinizing the man?
That is a very serious concern.
I mean, if we elevate a human figure to the point where his actions
are indistinguishable from God's actions, aren't we crossing a highly dangerous theological line?
Aren't we falling into the trap of worshiping a human being?
That is the most critical tension in the entire text, and the author navigates it with extreme precision.
He identifies 2 massive errors that people fall into when trying to understand this figure, and he marks a middle path between them.
What are the two errors?
On one side is the error of short sight.
These are people who judge the Imam by the standards of ordinary rulers.
The ones expecting a king.
Yes, they expect a king.
They see someone who
gives to the undeserving and withholds from the loyal and they fall into confusion.
They think he is an unjust man because they are measuring him against other men rather than recognizing he is demonstrating God's conduct.
They cannot see past the politics of a royal court.
But on the other side is the exact danger you just raised.
There are those who see the imam mirroring God's conduct and they become dazzled.
The author calls them the goo LAT.
The exaggerators.
Yes, the exaggerators.
They witness this divine impartiality.
They see him perfectly emulating the creator, and they inflate his office past its truth.
They falsely claim divinity for him.
So how does the author rescue his argument from the Goo-et?
How does he prove this figure is not God, while maintaining that his actions mirror God perfectly?
He provides the second required image of the text, and it is the key to resolving the entire doctrine.
The universal vice Jirhunt is like a shadow.
A shadow.
Yes, think of a shadow that perfectly imitates the thing that casts it.
When the caster moves, the shadow moves.
The shadow faithfully reproduces every outline, every gesture, every action of the caster.
But the shadow is never, for a single moment, the caster itself.
The shadow analogy holds the tension perfectly.
It does.
Because it contains both the perfection of the imitation and the absolute difference in substance between the two.
The shadow has no independent existence.
Its entire reality is contingent upon the one casting it.
Exactly.
The shadow doesn't exist without the caster.
So the vice turrent reproduces God's conduct exactly giving as God gives, withholding as God withholds.
but he remains entirely dependent, entirely human, a shadow cast upon the earth.
Near enough to God to reproduce his conduct exactly, and yet, being a shadow, never for a moment God himself.
That single image holds the truth that runs between the shortsighted and the exaggerators.
I concede the point.
The shadow resolves the friction for me.
I'm glad it landed.
It explains how this figure can govern both the AHLLHAQ, the people of truth, and the AHL albaya HL, the people of falsehood, with perfect divine impartiality, without ever breaking the strict bounds of theology.
He is not God.
He is the shadow demonstrating God's governance in the visible world.
And the author connects this reality directly to scripture, anchoring it in the concept of the vice-chergent.
He points to chapter 38, verse 26, where God addresses David.
saying, we have made you a vice jurgent on the earth, so judge between the people and truth.
So it's deeply rooted in the text.
Yes.
To be a vice agent in that verse is to govern God's servants as God would have them governed.
But the author argues that while past prophet kings fulfilled only a part of this duty, discharging A portion of God's manner of dealing the father of imams and the imam of the age who continues him,
fulfill it entirely.
They encompass the whole thing.
They perform the vice agency whole in both its worldly and religious conventions.
In worldly matters, the imam conceals the means of fortune and gives to deserving and undeserving alike.
Yes.
But in religious matters, he discloses.
He openly teaches the means of attaining wisdom, bestowing it generously on the worthy and distinguishing the people of truth from the people of falsehood.
He governs both worlds simultaneously, perfectly imitating the one who appointed him.
We have climbed a very steep, intricate intellectual ladder today.
The author has taken us from the metals of the earth to the outermost spheres, through the heart and limbs of historical guidance, to the very conduct of God mirrored in a living human being.
It is a massive scope.
But how does he land this immense philosophical weight?
He lands it not with a triumphant logical conclusion, but with a transition that changes the nature of the book itself.
He ends with a prayer.
A prayer.
Yes.
After spending the entire treatise proving that the world must have its summit and that the summit's dealings mirror God's own, the author turns from proving to asking.
he offers a closing supplication.
Why abandon the philosophical rigorousness at the very end?
It feels like a strange shift in tone for a text so heavily focused on logical proofs.
Because for the author, the elaborate argument was never the point in itself.
What was the point then?
The reasoning was a tool to reach a specific state of the soul, a state of gratitude and service.
He asks God to bestow upon his community a gratitude expressed not just in words, but in deeds and intentions.
He asked for the success to strive for the Imam of the age with hand, tongue, and heart.
The 3 instruments of a human life.
Exactly.
The body's action, the mouth's speech, and the heart's devotion.
All offered up in service.
Having proven that the Imam stands at the summit, the author asks only to be allowed to serve that summit truly.
The book dissolves in its last breath into worship.
The last note is the sound of a servant giving thanks for having been shown where to stand.
As we bring this exploration back to you, our listener, we have to ask what this means for your own life.
We do.
The author did not build this elaborate architecture just to leave it in the realm of theory.
He built it to confront us with the reality of a leader who gives without being paid, who governs without transaction, and who keeps the soul perfectly awake between fear and hope.
To ensure that reality is clear, we must state the core thesis of this work one final time, exactly as
before.
The imam treats people as God treats them, giving to the faithful and the faithfuls alike, seeking nothing in return, and that, not the power of a king, is the mark of God's vice Sandra.
The author challenges us to examine our own motivations in the light of that unconditional giving.
If the summit of human excellence demands the worship of the free devotion given not for a reward and not out of fear we have to look at our own lives, where do you serve for a wage and what would it take to give and worship as the free do this week?